WIFE OF DONALDMP A
OF DONALD ANKA, AND
TE IFRW D?ISSED AWAY AT  F
RAE EDD RE DITH
ERTOAI SAS R H KELFDE. ARO IN
ANLYSHGHHERUD TTDGTH
S D  ITHHES ON  SteMEUNUNCSE  LN
EDLOWA
IOWAR
ERINER A IP HAMP
HOr:NO TDIO RECO P
ATD LIICINE  YFO,  C KNASLUTDE
RARDOUON I
MTH ME  CREHAE  C.UN
DO
ESUN CKODCS SPNSERE  NTH
ITATREHE
ULD
MP RONEIFRONMEOF C SHG LONDMENDE
. AYONCI
'8E , D Y.E, TWALAN1OGGHM. IWA
HEVER TAMBSHFEZEE
ND ATR BESO O B DAB
WRUWSIOUUNE TH Y BU
ULT  N S A PR0sTHTHEMSE ATHMENDE
CHTU IR ANATD EDEM
EIBETTT E . D ESTHS.
ENTIECD  TLLNERE
A WAK
KEATNDE RALSISEEITHR LE A
NDPOS R . TT
IPENCOEAON
DSUMES GSSSIA TMA ONTUATORUENFA
NGID. L RRDILLAMSHLET L DEA AN
DD SWA,
E TO  HIAVO EY BAE FR. RES F,IVE
TEN TAISGERCTHSSWAOMTHGLANON
DE,ROADS E AM
ON T
ETUG
OR
OR T
WIMO